now to Washington where speculation is
rife that President Donald Trump's
firing of his national security advisor
John Bolton could signal a shift in u.s.
foreign policy announcing the latest
White House sacking on Twitter the
president said that he disagreed
strongly with Bolton on many issues
Bolton for his part was a hardliner
on several of those issues he gave a
different version of events saying that
he offered his resignation John Bolton
in happier times seated at the
president's side an influential
proponent of a hawkish foreign policy
but his tenure as national security
adviser came to an end when Trump took
to Twitter to announce his departure the
president tweeted that he strongly
disagreed with many of Bolton's
suggestions prompting Trump to ask for
his resignation Bolton quickly disputed
this version of events in turn tweeting
that he had offered to resign of his own
accord it's not the first time Trump and
Bolton have disagreed the former adviser
stood for a muscular approach to foreign
relations unknown hardliner he favored
military intervention in Iran North
Korea and Venezuela but despite his
aggressive rhetoric Trump often chose
diplomacy over confrontation he has met
North Korea's leader Kim jong-un and was
prepared to strike a peace deal with the
Taliban in Afghanistan Bolton's
departure has fueled speculation that
u.s. foreign policy could mellow further
but senior administration officials
against that idea someone asked what
would the policy be different absent any
individual being here this have been the
president's policies but I don't think
any leader around the world should make
any assumption that because someone of
asset of hearts that the president
Trump's foreign policy will change in a
materialized
sanctions designed to pressure Iran into
concessions over its nuclear program are
likely to remain in place I would say
Secretary of Pompeo and myself and the
president are completely aligned on our
maximum pressure campaign I think you
we've done more sanctions on Iran and
anybody and it's absolutely working even
as Bolton became the third National
Security Advisor to serve under
President Trump venusian brushed off
suggestions that the national security
team was in disarray absolutely not
that's the most ridiculous question I've
ever heard of but Bolton is unlikely to
be the last official to find himself
going out of the revolving door of
trumps White House
do you have used Pablo Foley Elias looks
back on the fraught relationship between
John Bolton and Donald Trump and what
Bolton's departure could mean for the
future of US policy it's been widely
reported here in the United States that
the relationship between President
Donald Trump and the now former national
security adviser John Bolton had been
strained
they had a fraught relationship in debt
in the past days weeks and months just
over the weekend we know that there is a
big difference of opinion over a
president Donald Trump's decision to
invite the Taliban leaders to Camp David
for secret talks in a diplomatic effort
to end the u.s. is longest-running war
of course the war in Afghanistan and
there were also differences of opinion
between the two over at the handling of
the USS relationship with Iran now in
recent weeks we've seen how President
Trump has been more open to the idea of
meeting the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani we know that John Bolton was
very much against that and also he was
very displeased and at President Donald
Trump's decision to meet the North
Korean leader Kim Jung on so there would
there were many differences over what
direction the president is taking a u.s.
foreign policy and this more
conciliatory tone towards the u.s. as
enemies seems to be something that John
Bolton was very much against the
question now is who is going to take
over from him he whoever comes in will
be the fourth national security adviser
to serve in the Trump administration and
whoever that may be it's been speculated
here in the United States will
to be somebody who has who is more
aligned with president Trump's more
conciliatory tone towards its enemies